what's the big importance of winning
material why is it so important for us
to win material what does it give us
someone will tell me that not I cannot
go on yes well they will have less mom
they will have less material right so
you have a bigger army do you prefer to
be commanding a bigger army or smaller
army that's the logic why do you prefer
your team to be bigger than the opponent
or less doesn't matter what sport you're
playing bigger right so that most most
most basic logic will start applying
here so how are we gonna win material
most basic thing we are going to capture
right yeah we're not having some groups
or Knights of Queens dropping from the
sky we actually gonna capture and get
more material this is one thing that is
really important and for that we
discussed several tactical ideas to win
material for example would a fork be a
way to win material what is a fork who
can tell me what and your main goal is
going to be winning material for example
who is the which piece is the one that
we see most forks with there's one
specific piece exactly a night and night
when a night actually comes for example
why Knight to d square attacking
checking the king and attacking the rook
that is one that is fork which are them
make which other ideas we have touched
last week tactical ideas which are they
skewers excellent same idea right we
said it like the food we were actually
hungry last week we're amazingly enough
you're still hungry not lunchtime but
why do you mention it it's just like ask
you there's several pieces lined up on a
line or diagonal and we have a way to
attack them and win material so okay
accent where folks we have excused what
else do we have
pains and do you remember two types of
pins there are two types of pins right
normal pin what is an absolute pin like
why can't it move legislature pure
doofus excellent
so this bishop is pinned right it cannot
move doesn't matter what if even if he
has to take a queen oh because the king
is just behind it let's say this was the
position the bishop is still pinned kay
but can he move would it be smart for
him to move but he can so that's a
difference between an absolute pin you
could not move at all and just a pin
okay it's not smart to play that move
perfect what is the discovered check
okay so who can tell me someone else
does right have a good discovered check
in this position yes excellent move
Bishop Defoe
the book is checking the King and the
bishop is threatening and you're going
to win material so all those ideas they
are pretty much the main ones we can
think about some smaller one but really
folks and pains and skewers and discover
checks or discovered attack they are
really going to be our main ideas for
winning material now other type of
tactical ideas are used to go after the
King not to win material we said the
logic is and in most games that's really
what we see when you see best players in
the world play or decent class what does
it matter which level there is no really
checkmate right I mean Anand I don't
know how many times I cannot think even
when you really go checkmated what we do
have is that one player is under huge
attack being under a lot a lot of
pressure in order to get out of the
attack he gives away some material and
then you get into a position that is
down a pawn or a night or two
something like that I'm losing because
is down material so really really really
there is no checkmate in grandmasters
world or very very few checkmates
grandmasters world champion strong
players because they will defend they
will not get check me but in order to
defend they will have to pay material so
that's the important part
we touched last time much more the topic
of material let's touch the topic of the
King this time now we have several ways
to attack the King - checkmate it right
one of the ways and this is what we will
start doing few puzzles here is who can
tell me what the topic here will be
perfect background checkmate okay we
done our homework so this is one very
very important idea that we see in
endless endless kids just like you games
and tournaments endless one of the
players get to a one of his heavy pieces
to the back rank and the black king is a
white king of course get checkmated
before we even touch the move that you
was played you know what let's first see
it so we want to get our work into the
back rank and we actually can take the
Queen but is taking the Queen that in
that impressive it's just going to be an
exchange right it's just going to be an
exchange Queen - Queen want a queen yes
why did get something I just wonder this
is not our topic but can someone tell me
in principle what did white gain tiny
bit by capturing yes right and double
pawns it's completely another topic
double pawns in general are not really
bad they are not really bad but double
isolated pawn almost always really bad
for example if this was the position
this this is not this is not that much
because you have a complex of pawns here
that cover a lot of squares so double
pawns by definition not really bad
I mean sometimes they can be a bit
sometimes they can be actually powerful
but double isolated pawn right isolated
means there's nothing on this side right
now by themselves they are almost always
very weak so that was excellent double
isolated for example black pawn can
never control this query as a big hole
over f5 even the King tiny weak but that
would not be that much for white most
likely this game would end up in a draw
but white is still getting exactly the
advantage that you mentioned but before
I could even say a word already several
of you pointed out that yes
what would why play right exactly
white sees that black is no escaping
squares no escaping squares at all so
how can you get to the back rank to pay
price of a queen is meaningless when
you're in checkmate right you will pay
any price it's just the game is over so
white gave material but we don't even
look at that and then wookie 8 is
checking yes yeah I've seen that many of
you immediately suggested it so a quick
question a quick question what is
usually the easiest way and many many
times you see experienced players just
play this move it's not really necessary
immediately to have that move on the
board but it's kind of a very
prophylactic a move just you know what
it's healthy to have it there yes
exactly and usually it is the h-bond
right which is something like you know
you have a flashlight in your home there
is no electricity breakdown right now
but when there will be you don't need to
start thinking about where you find
candles right you just go and you can
use it this is basically like one of
those moves they're just healthy healthy
to have in the position you might use it
you might not actually much more than a
flashlight that light or maybe once a
year you do get problems with
electricity this you get a lot a lot a
lot actually some of the greatest game
moves by great player will play just
this quiet tiny move that at some point
in the future some point there's a very
very famous game between Victor Coach no
that was three times vice world champion
against actually Boris Spassky that was
world champion coach Knight played at
some position incredible tiny slow move
h3 just so in many moves ahead in a
fourth line you will have this
possibility to play king h2 and one was
if I'm not mistaken in game in their
match in 1977 so very very correct to
this point white is to play if neck to
play is move simple it's black smooth
simple in this position what would black
play if it is is move you in g2 right
that's what checkmate one of the
simplest move made extremely basic
pattern that's actually the next topic
that we will see after checkmate on the
back rank we will see how to checkmate a
king that Castle just very basic
checkmate patterns so Queen g2 is
checkmate okay does white have a way to
stop Queen G - first of all how
for example if your knight was here you
could have told me hey I'm gonna play 93
okay you're controlling this square
right so you're stopping cringy too but
the night is here
China far away from there yes what would
you play with white ah all right we
cannot we cannot get this one too deeply
yes is it going to stop Quincy to
checkmate unless unless you have an AI
file bless you
unless you can go after Quincy too - I
file this this is going to be checkmate
right you are correct that if you have
an extra move you if this is the
position you can actually play who g1n
cover this square yes but are you are
you getting - G - okay so so I would
look at the position and say after I
mean it white cannot cover G - yeah but
but how can I get a pawn bad white white
white cannot get his pawns to control
the g2 square so let's say this we
looked at the position for a beat white
cannot control the g2 school simple so
what is about to get checkmated unless
yes okay it's a check does it guarantee
anything not maybe does well let's see
so you want to play Bishop takes e7
black as one move to play right
black will play Luke take bishop what
will then why play okay great you got
you bought yourself one more move to
live but is it more than that or not yes
Mook hey check ok but if you know what
actually let's put a pawn here just so
nobody after it will say hey 1 and you
forgot to put this pawn it's the same
idea but there is actually a big
importance here ok yes
na but this night xc70 first move what
does it mean by false move does your
opponent have to do something I know
what you want you want Knight xt7 and
then you are saying something that I've
seen about everyone everyone there was
no key that I've done chess with that at
some point didn't do exactly the same in
many times
exactly exactly the same thing I
captured something so what's the logic I
capture something so my opponent has to
capture back seriously does he have to
this is job to help you egg but it's
exactly the thing I captured something
so and it happens to clear that our 5
years older than all of you and if play
chess for many years and our experts
very strong kids but it's the way of
taking oh it took here I have to take
you this is one square out of another 63
that are available on the board I can
take but then I know you will be smiling
at me and play rook d8 and I know but
you know this is cutest you are right
now we are enemies we are playing I'm
not here to help you so what will I play
with black ah
what will I play with black what was our
original idea what reflects original
idea
well the disk well disappeared did you
take the pawn and I say mama me like to
concede seven now I'm not gonna check my
team not really right I'm gonna play
Queen g2 checkmate
so not really scared okay but actually
we're doing through the process of doing
puzzles we get to think a lot about what
are we thinking right and wrong again
what's the process the process is much
is in most of the situation what going
to lead you to the right move nothing
else so not gonna help yes but after
work take okay what would black play
after it I know it's difficult we are
going to see if we can do that without
moving the pieces it's a lot of moose
then we will move it so Bishop take you
know what let's just make one step
bishop take okay the black have to take
him or not it has to take has to well
that's a different story then well he is
going to take it has to it's not
checkmate okay but now look d8 right ah
does how many moves does black have in
this position now if white has something
to show here you will be very happy if
he doesn't he's toast yes
was this your your move as well no what
you were going to play
but this is the checkmate threat right
plus like you can just capture it but
let me walk to a8 very good what is
black gonna play here have to take and
check it so we got checkmate on the back
rank only that it involved much much
much more effort alright if you're gonna
think you are going to have any game
positions ok I'm going to do to play the
amazing move I'm going to lift my work
put it on the back rank and it's going
to be checkmate ok well that's ok for
the first tournament that you will play
chess for the second one this is for
much much much higher level White had to
work and he worked for moves for
involving giving his bishop then giving
the rook but got black in a checkmate
net on the background by the way we did
study something super important actually
from this puzzle I didn't intend it to
be we studied something about forcing
moves they are the most important part
when we calculate in chess why is that
because if I if it has to play something
is it going to be easier for me to
anticipate the future you have to
instead of looking and same thing I will
play this move then my opponent can play
this this this and that then I can play
this this this then you can play we will
get so so many possibilities this
actually what happens a lot in chess the
maximum that we can narrow how many
possibilities we have to calculate it
doesn't mean that it's good for us but
it means that it is easier for us to
calculate this was the straight line
let's look at it again anew tell me if
it was a straight line or not by
straight line I mean black had to play
every move that he did play he had to so
you tell me at what point black had more
than one move white played Bishop takes
the servant
how many moves as black have to play
here how many move can you play one to
one everyone agrees on why played look
da how many moves get black play here
one so we are still in a straight line
by straight line I mean I walk walk walk
I don't need to make any turn right
there are no two possibilities one major
possibilities okay
why played Luke a eight how many moves
can black play here so I continue my
straight line it's very easy very very
easy to see well much easier let's use
that term much easier to see straight
distance no trees nothing butter you
know turns no curves than anything else
and that's it so from this part actually
we cut it bless you with that this super
important topic of forcing move white to
play here first of all use black
threatening checkmate yes where is next
threatening checkmate actually on two
squares right
excellent both of those moves going to
be checkmate okay
why did maybe why I can't think about
playing a move like this maybe running
with the Queen okay that's a possibility
it's actually not going to be that great
for white but it's a possibility to get
out of checkmate does white have
something more powerful and I will give
you a clue it involves their back ranked
things all something that's going to
happen on the background
yes
came to see one yeah we said this is the
difference move to get out of checkmate
but I want more what would be worse in
this position you'd probably be losing
but it's you're correct it's a way to
get out of checkmate angry I want more
for white yes Queen to a3 actually will
protect against Queen B - checkmate but
we mentioned that there are true
checkmate sets black is threatening one
is Queen B - and the other one is Queen
a1 and Queen a3 is not going to cover
the a1 square yes white will play Quint
okay so you're giving your queen for a
book when you give you a queen for a
book you better have something to show
for it right do you think you have
something to show for you okay let's see
what you have so you're gonna take okay
and okay I'm going to take well you
start it so you have to finish what now
base your place by the way then let's do
it right you step-by-step so after we
played Queen take how many moves does
black have here
how many League one move one uno one
move and you wanna play Bishop h6 check
how many move does black have here one
which one King be it and now you're
gonna play with white excellent job and
once again our straight line making it
much easier for us to calculate right we
have to see the idea which is not easy
and especially starting with a
combination that gives away our Queen
just by instinct is not something that
we should well think about giving away
material but excellent job black king is
left defenseless on their background
okay
this was one idea involving their back
rank actually this was very forcing idea
in a just winning the game other ideas
will it be going after the King and we
are going from I think
some the things that are most practical
ones this what I want to touch today
maybe next week we will touch some other
ideas and just some calculations
principles let's look at this position
we are going to touch something that we
will continue we will continue next week
so whatever going to show up next week
we will continue from this point let's
look at this position you know what and
we'll be super fair so what's the
material advantage in this position
material material situation so does one
side that material advantage on
but white as in return but what does
white have in return for the bishop how
do we how do we calculate material when
you look at the position when you look
at a position and someone asks you like
me hey who has more material what's the
right way to do that yes it's even
material but the easiest yes but but if
we look overall and actually how should
we do it in the easiest way just like
when we see a number written okay we
will start by looking at the high pieces
so white as a queen black at the Queen
right are they even we start always with
their high pieces it makes it much
easier white has two looks black has to
work we don't need to count it we know
that both sides are equal right so we
can throw it away
why does a knight black at the knight
black has a be shop and white as a
knight so really when you won and that
just completed white as five pounds and
black is five pounds so the material is
equal with the slight indifference that
black has a big shot and white has a
knight and overall totally equal
material everything else is just the
same like you have an equation
everything Same Same Same Same fine in
the Europe
two last parts that are there okay so
equal material both kids F Castle and
that's going to be the topic that we
will start a bit now and just take it AG
immediately from there next week playing
against the castle King I will let you
think for a minute maybe you can come up
and tell me which idea why it has in
this position
if you do you have checkmate in one move
you have an idea approach ow
how will you play checkmate in one move
Queen to h7 would be would be checkmate
but the knight is there okay but the
night is the perfect okay so we need we
need our I remember that we need our
parents help sometimes okay so parents
helped everything they show the idea
queen take eight seven let's do this is
the idea and actually we will speak
about the way to think because that was
very important what happened now
but it's queen take it seven checkmate
no because the knight is defending yes
that's exactly the way and you used even
the term of getting rid of the knight
but by the way before we gonna play it
on the boat let's say before we gonna
play it on the boat 95s actually a
brilliant moving is winning the game
let's say that you know where are we
going to put the screen I don't know
what's a decent spot for the screen
let's put it just for our purposes we're
going to put it on here okay and we will
not allow white to move a look to d1
which is best move would you no no but
actually this is not this is not a great
spot let me think why would I want to
put my knight that is very good I will
put it okay I will have to tiny tiny bit
modify the position because if not it's
not going to work that easy let me put
this one here and the bishop and the
bishop you okay
we tiny tiny bit modify the position the
same ideas before applied Queen take it
7 would be checkmate but the night is
here so a question
would 95 be such amazingly powerful
strong move in this position
well what would black play here what
would black play if I place 95 the
threat you mention it you wanna
eliminate the night and then checkmate
okay that would be under tactical ideas
of remove of the defender this whatever
you want to call it okay but there's
like a way to defend you
well yes g6g 6 is the night he'll
defended defended by the bishop g6 and
pretty much nothing for white here not
much even take the pawn is not so clear
what is the difference what is the
difference in our position after 95 what
is the difference yes remember what we
said 20 minutes ago 30 minutes ago
what did we said how many games does
Grandmaster lose by getting checkmated
very few but when their material
difference is becoming that big well the
game is over for example more every one
every decent player that has played
enough would resign here why he will see
that he's getting checkmated all or
losing the Queen he can prevent
checkmate
he can't prevent checkmate but at the
price of use material and that's how
chess games are really won not by oh I
take and checkmate but the black will
design you not because he is getting
checkmate but because to avoid checkmate
he has to suffer substantial material
losses and that's exactly the move 95 is
going to win a lot of material all
checkmate so what was our process here
and that's why I said I really liked
what we had before the process of a
chess player is this looking at the
position with white
one is saying oh wow Queen take it seven
is checkmate will be checkmate what is
the obstacle knight on f6 can I somehow
make that Knight disappear if I can make
the knight disappear it would be
checkmate right that's how we build it
how would I want to make the knight
disappear by the way in the most forcing
way or not always we want to look at
most forcing Lea let's look at another
square again again this is what we will
be doing most of our paths all the
puzzles next week are going to be with
this topic let's look at such position
I'll make it very very very simple not
putting away too many pieces not making
not making it more complicated than it
should be okay we have a position with
opposite castles now position with
opposite castles right White Castle to
the Queen side black castle to the King
side what is the character of positions
with opposite castles what would you say
in general would it be a more solid play
would it be more aggressive play would
we go for it yes more aggressive why
so we suit so it's easier for us to
attack right because we can move forces
on one side of the boat another thing
can stay and I was ok and I would think
you stay safe on the other side I
thought I thought I said something
ridiculously wrong like I said ok take
it back but ok it wasn't me
ok so we have a position very classical
one which castle on opposite side which
means we want to consider attacking yes
excellent it's not the best move but
it's the right way of thinking it's not
the right move but it's the right way of
thinking excellent Queen eight six what
are you threatening with Queen eight six
oh if you cannot take the Queen it spin
no it cannot take so but what would like
try after Queen eight six
what would like play because that's
excellent that's how we think is it
going to resign
no so what will we play
well what is the threat after Queen
eight-six I want to put it without
moving the pieces what is the threat
after Queen eight-six ah make Queen take
g7 checkmate okay so how is black gonna
prevent it he has to prevent it if not
if checkmated if not yeah I design yes
but I will take I will take Queen on
eight six threatening to take on G seven
years but but the train left at station
you will move the rook I will still play
Queen take g7 you are making effort to
make space for your king but no you need
five moves to get the King away from
there
yes jcx Thank You g6 Queen eight six
white we have to think that way there is
no other way to play chess no other way
white wants to play Queen take g7 you
can move the walk you can move this look
you can do flip-flops whatever you want
unless you can defend this pawn thumbs
up if the Queen was here you could have
told me okay I'm going to play Queen
ePHI defending okay we can discuss that
that's a decent move g6 is the only move
very good job only move to the prevent
checkmate okay you can give your queen
for a check for one more but play queen
here you will take it other than that
Queen g7 is checkmate but just fix it a
good move and not very easy for white
how to continue so now we understood all
of us there is a threat of checkmating
there but black can play g6 and defend
does white have a way to overcome that
the right have a way to win here pretty
much by force
it does your job is to tell me how
any thought which one you want to play
Queen g5 same story right I'll give you
one minute two minutes and if not
okay let's start with the excellent job
very good check
okay no no we are not dependent on the
opponent making a mistake I mean here
chess games are being won like that but
in a different type of we play queen
eight-six you can say oh maybe my
opponent will forget win deserve it no
it will play g6 that was suggested here
look tech g7 if King h8 was asked well
why took a huge pot but now Queen eight
six and how to prevent checkmate on
eight seven I don't know because there
is no way so black is going to take now
what yes Queen g5 check how many moves
does black have in this position now
what Queen a sick check how many moves
black a CEO and now well
Queen g2 and then check me exactly so
there was tiny possibility for black on
the first move to go king h6 King h8 and
Queen eight six check make very very
first line this is the difference
between allowing the opponent to get out
of a threat or just forcing it again our
straight line and those are basic
patterns against a king that already
castled and we will take a pause here
will tell Ben maybe to call it chapter
one and we will continue that next week
with well chapter two something like
that
you